hi there steve kaufman today i'm going
to talk about language learning as it
relates to
learning the
language of one's ancestors or the
heritage language as the
as it's fashionable now to call this the
language of your country of origin if
you're an immigrant where do i stand on
it i had two
emails or two uh
messages at youtube i can't remember
which uh one person said that he's
married to a lady from hong kong he's
trying to get his kids to learn
cantonese do i have any advice what did
i do
uh and then another person said that uh
he wishes his parents had insisted that
he learned flemish he didn't do so and
this has cut him off from members of his
family and
sort of challenging me for not being
keen on
the idea of learning the ancestral
language
so where do i stand on this my view is
that to learn any language takes an
awful lot of motivation
so if the child of an immigrant is very
motivated to learn
the language of origin because he or she
wants to talk to their grandmother
grandfather whatever
uh that's great
that's great
however if they're not motivated to do
so then they should just be left alone
uh i don't think that there's any
particular
greater moral
obligation value in having someone learn
the language of one's ancestors the
language of one's ethnic group
rather than some other language
um
you know it's if i take my own case
uh you know my parents were born in the
austro-hungarian empire they were german
speaking
in a jewish community in moravia
the austro-hungarian empire or at least
moravia became czechoslovakia so they
spoke mostly german but at some point
they started going to czech schools once
czechoslovakia was formed so they spoke
both of those languages
uh
they but german was more natural for
them
then they left in 39 before hitler came
in and went to sweden which is where i
was born and so for the first five years
of my life from 45 to 50
1945 to 1950 i spoke swedish
and then we uh emigrated to canada and
my parents decided that we're now in
canada we're going to speak english and
i always spoke english with my parents
and that was fine i never had any sense
that i
my communication with my parents was in
any way inhibited
there was no pressure to learn german or
czech
if anything my parents wanted me to
learn french which we studied at school
without any great success
uh and they were quite happy that we
spoke english because we lived in canada
uh and of course
kids are
very interested in
in
hanging around with their peers
and so i think there's it's difficult to
get kids to learn the ancestral language
some are interested
uh some are interested uh some are not
and but as i say i don't think there's
any great moral
value like this fellow who says he's mad
at his father for not forcing him to
speak dutch
uh
well learn it then you know i don't know
how old this person is but i'm 66 and
i'm learning czech now started uh you
know ten months ago
uh i've learned a number of languages uh
in the last uh ten years go out and
learn it how can you blame your parents
because in reality and back in those
days you probably weren't very
interested it's like in my own case
i might say i wish my mother had
insisted that i continue taking piano
lessons but i didn't want to do it and
so eventually after fighting day after
day after day
around the piano she let me quit
so it's no point in hindsight now to say
that i wish she had forced me
uh it was just too much effort because i
didn't want to do it
uh
i you know developed my interest and and
so far as languages are concerned uh the
first second language that i learned was
french
you know the first language that i spent
besides english that i learned to speak
well was french followed by chinese and
then japanese and then probably spanish
and german so it had nothing to do with
whatever might be considered the
language of my ancestors
my wife
who was born in macau and whose mother
is costa rican
so therefore her the language she spoke
the best was cantonese
but the language of her mother was
spanish
so now in terms of our kids
uh which ancestral language should we we
be forcing them to learn
um
you know as it was i couldn't even get
them to learn french which i tried very
hard to do the more we tried the more
they resisted
it wasn't until my son mark
had the opportunity to uh to live in
different foreign countries as a
professional hockey player but he became
interested in learning languages
so you know i just think language
learning is something you do if you're
interested
if the parents can create an environment
where the children are genuinely
interested in learning the language then
they might be able to pull it off in
many cases they won't and in some cases
they might actually
uh turn the kid off
uh learning that language so and and to
me the culture is not in the dna like we
have immigrants here from uh
from i don't know latin america so
someone who comes here from chile
argentina brazil mexico i mean those
people are also mixed so is the
ancestral language spanish or is it is
it arabic if they're of lebanese origin
i know lebanese origin mexicans i know
uh you know jewish mexicans i know
uh you know there are uh
japanese brazilians african origin
so what's the ancestral language like
how how many generations are you gonna
go back with this
and the reality is that in all
probability in canada within a few
generations all those people will
intermarry and only speak english uh
in canada by the third generation you
know two-thirds of the people
uh have uh spouses
who are not of the same ethnic group and
so english just simply takes over so uh
people get very moralistic about this
you know it's just so obviously a good
thing to learn
you know the ancestral language it's
part of your heritage it's uh you know
diversity and blah blah blah
yeah if people do it that's fine nothing
wrong with it uh
but if they don't like doing it that's
equally fine equally fine in in my
opinion
uh let people learn the languages that
they're interested in
um i don't know if there's much more uh
to say oh yeah insofar as what we did
with our kids i mean we tried very hard
we would travel we sent our kids to
french summer camp
we uh when we lived in ottawa we sent
them to a bilingual school
uh we traveled in france i had a french
tape going in the car and all it did was
build up resistance the kids just hated
it and they still
talk about it
just didn't work
uh that's not that we didn't try and it
wasn't because it was the ancestral
language it's just because i
we wanted them to speak another language
one possibly more eventually and
it didn't work so i'm not a big fan of
all of this and you may know that i'm
not a big fan of multiculturalism in
other words the ideology of
multiculturalism celebrate celebrate the
differences as if you know uh countries
like canada should be as diverse as
possible on the other hand the countries
of origin should be as
as uh
culturally uh you know
uh homogeneous as possible uh so the
whole thing is full of contradictions
but it creates jobs for people it's a
big political boondoggle and
an opportunity for a lot of politically
correct people to feel
very proud of themselves but has no
intrinsic value in my view so thank you
for listening bye for now